joining me now is Missouri Senator Josh
Hawley Senator good to have you on
tonight
what is the solution here because I have
a lot of friends uh who are chattering
in my ear day in and day out and they
say well look we want the Republicans to
win but Republicans when they get into
power they tend to punt these big issues
and government never gets cut what are
we going to say
well I think what we've seen Laura in
the last two years is we've gotten an up
close look at the corruption that is in
our government whether we're talking
about the FBI whether we're talking
about doj or whether we're talking about
the kind of self-dealing that you have
just outlined and Republicans need to
get serious about rooting out this
corruption it has got to be priority
number one by the way Congress can start
with itself you want to talk about not
doing self-dealing how about Congress
pass an actual stock trading ban which
is what I propose if Republicans want to
lead on this issue this ought to be
something that they run on this ought to
be something that we pledge to do I've
introduced the legislation let's get it
done and once we ban stock trading among
members of Congress let's turn to doj
let's turn to the FBI let's have a top
to bottom review of what's going on at
these increasingly corrupt agencies it
is time to give this government back to
the American people but lord it's not
going to happen unless we root out the
corruption well and I think you raise
raised the dod and this is like the
subject about which we can never speak
if we're Republicans you could never cut
the Department of Defense you can never
cut military spending because then
you're anti-military
well I've called this out Senator and I
think it's time for Republicans to get
real on this issue because there is
enormous waste Fraud and Abuse across
government including at the Pentagon
where we spend most of our money in the
budget at least do you agree
well you know well listen look at the
pentagon look at what they're spending a
lot of that money on Laura it's these
woke policies in the military I mean you
see right now they're in the midst of a
major recruiting crisis our military is
which is which is terrible and it's
dangerous for the country but why is
that the case it's because they are
forcing critical race Theory this wokism
across the military and they're spending
taxpayer dollars to do it so do we need
to review what's going on with the
Pentagon you bet we do there shouldn't
be a dime spent on this critical race
Theory nonsense there shouldn't be a
dime spent on this woke Theory but that
is a top priority of this Administration
under Joe Biden's leadership so yeah
there needs to be a top to bottom review
that's the kind of corruption frankly
that I'm talking about and Republicans
need to lead on it now here's one of uh
I think DC's biggest swamp creature
Senator Congressman Jamie Raskin who was
ranting on and on about the prospect of
holding these government bureaucrats
accountable for bias watch
professional civil servants must be able
to do their jobs without fear of
retaliation and discharge for political
reasons the previous administration
attempted to turn our civil service Mr
Speaker into a top-down political and
ideological Party Machine the 50 000
civil servants deemed to be involved in
formulating policy could have been swept
up in his schedule F political Purge
senator they are sweating a review of
the Civil Service and this is at a time
where most government employees are
still not back in the office
they're not even here yeah exactly and
that the weather by the way that review
the Civil Service needs to happen Laura
we absolutely need to look at what is
happening in the civil service but
listen you want to talk about
politicizing the Civil Service look at
this Administration look what they've
done to the FBI look at what they've
done to the Department of Justice look
at the fact that they are conducting
raids on on pro-life Catholic
demonstrators to what make a point look
at what they've done to parents sending
the FBI to their doors if they go to
school board meetings and complain I
mean you want to talk about politicizing
things this is exactly the kind of
corruption that needs to be investigated
that needs to be rooted out and finally
I just say this let's not forget who
told FBI whistleblowers not to come
forward it was Merit Garland who sent a
memo out to all doj employees and said
don't talk to Congress don't blow the
whistle you've got to go through me
that's not the law so you talk about
double standards Laura it's double
standards all around and that's why
Republicans have got to make an anti
corruption agenda priority number one
yeah and you agree it should be agency
by agency no one spared
no one spared absolutely we need to look
at what they're doing with taxpayer
money we need to look at what they're
doing in terms of pushing this woke
policies we need to look at the
self-dealing in terms of the stock
trading and the insider trading all of
it needs to be on the table if Americans
send Republicans back to Congress and
majorities and I think they will this is
what they'll be electing us to do is to
protect their interests the people's
interests and to stand up for them
Senator great to see you thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else